[Musica]
quando nel secolo scorso studiavo
medicina
il mio interesse per le malattie
infettive era guardato un po con
sorpresa le malattie infettive
sembravano un problema che riguardava i
paesi in via di sviluppo la ricerca
l'innovazione andava nella direzione
delle malattie cardiovascolari della
neurologia soprattutto del cancro
invece io avevo questo interesse che a
distanza di tanti anni è tornato a galla
ed è inventato straordinariamente
attuale già allora avevamo avuto la
doccia fredda della comparsa dell'aids
che aveva messo in un certo senso alla
nostra sicurezza di mondo ricco
occidentale un pochino all'angolo ma un
po la narrazione
stigmatizzante che faceva credere che in
fondo fosse una malattia che riguardava
solo alcune categorie di persone e poi
col passare del tempo rapidamente lo
sviluppo di farmaci sempre più efficaci
nel tenere sotto controllo l'infezione
da hiv
ci hanno fatto tornare in una
tranquillità nel pensare che in fondo
anche light anche le infezioni da hiv
erano un problema che riguardava i paesi
più poveri ma che noi in fondo davanti
alle malattie infettive eravamo
assolutamente
sicuri basta valigie ne bastavano gli
antibiotici bastavano i vaccini oggi
tutti quanti ci confrontiamo con una
realtà molto diversa questa pandemia ha
paralizzato ha messo in ginocchio tutto
il pianeta è però dei segnali di allarme
li avevamo già avuti il nostro secolo
questo xxi secolo è stato caratterizzato
dalla comparsa prima di sars che è stata
molto contenuta
diversa che è pure rimasta limitata ad
alcune aree del nostro pianeta ma questo
nuovo coronavirus invece ha messo tutti
davanti alla
fragilità che deriva a l'essere umano
così forte così tecnologico così
vincente davanti a un microscopico
granello di materiale genetico e di
proteine che mette in discussione tutto
dall'economia ai rapporti sociali ai
rapporti inter personali e questo
questa minaccia è subito apparsa nelle
prime settimane come una pandemia
quindi come un qualcosa che riguardava
tutto il mondo tutto il pianeta non solo
i paesi più poveri non solo alcune
categorie di persone tutti ci siamo
trovati esposti davanti a questa
minaccia è da questa pandemia fin
dall'inizio l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità ha detto siamo sulla stessa
barca siamo nella stessa situazione ne
possiamo uscire solo tutti insieme in
realtà la priorità di mettere di
guardare il pianeta come un unico
soggetto della lotta contro questa
pandemia è stata tradita in questi mesi
in realtà noi ci siamo
messi in condizione di essere più
protetti tramite
soprattutto grazie ai vaccini mentre
altri paesi sono ancora più esposti
questa differenza è è grave e che cosa
possiamo fare per per superarla per
affrontare insieme questa cosa
molti invocano la rimozione dei propri
dei brevetti che è una parte del
problema in questo caso diversamente che
per l'aids per le infezioni da hiv una
piccola parte del problema
da cosa perché dico questo in africa
viene e sta sono stati somministrati
circa la metà dei vaccini finora forniti
l'africa è un mondo ci sono enorme
differenze tra un paese e l'altro ci
sono paesi del continente africano come
il marocco che hanno una buona ottenuto
una buona copertura vaccinale e altri
dove praticamente non è vaccinato
nessuno penso alla repubblica
democratica del congo dove è vero che
sono stati consegnati
solo il 2 per cento dei vaccini
necessari a proteggere la popolazione
ma è anche vero che ne sono stati
effettivamente somministrati il 4 per
cento di quel 2 per cento quindi è
evidente che c'è un problema di
forniture ma c'è un grosso problema
a valle di questo c'è una corsa a
ostacoli che dobbiamo superare per
portare i vaccini a tutto il mondo cosa
che ripeto è la nostra priorità in
questo momento è come si può fare questa
corsa ostacolo deve superare degli
ostacoli che sono ambientali logistici
di personale perché occorre il personale
sanitario e anche di accettazione da
parte delle persone
cosa si sta facendo la tecnologia ci sta
venendo avanti ci sta avendo in aiuto
con con molte molte idee e stato gia per
esempio
brevettato un sistema per utilizzare i
vaccini già esistenti in modo che
possano essere trasportati ovunque senza
le difficoltà imposte dalla catena del
freddo si stanno mettendo a punto
vaccini
totalmente nuovi che non richiedono la
preparazione e poi li iniezione
che deve necessariamente effettuare del
personale competente e che richiede poi
tutti tutte quelle cautele di
conservazione che ben conosciamo stanno
mettendo già stati creati dei vaccini
per esempio che possono essere
somministrati tramite un cerotto con 400
micro a ghetti che oltre a superare la
paura dell'ago per chi c'era
permettono di trasportare questo
materiale
spedirlo senza nessun limite di
temperatura e di umidità e di altre
caratteristiche alcuni di questi vaccini
pensate su questi cerotti si stanno
producendo con le tecniche 3d con le
stampanti 3d ma poi ce ne sono altri
altri altre idee altre linee di ricerca
per la seconda la terza la quarta
generazione di vaccini anti comiche e
poi forse serviranno anche per portare
più facilmente altri vaccini a
protezione di altre malattie in queste
aree più sfortunate
penso per esempio ai vaccini per bocca
che per ora nel caso di covit sono
ancora molto indietro ma è chiaramente
permettono una sommessa molto più
semplice o ancora invece questo è un
bacino molto avanti nella sua
fase di sperimentazione
un vaccino prodotto dalle piante piante
geneticamente modificate per produrre un
vaccino e quindi potremmo avere un
domani delle piantagioni di vaccini ecco
quindi noi abbiamo la tecnologia che è
lanciata l'innovazione è lanciata per
aiutarci a
rispondere a questa priorità che è
diventata
imprevedibilmente la nostra priorità
questa del difenderci da un virus ma
dobbiamo fare questo tenendo presente
quello che dicono gli esperti cioè che
non è un
caso una situazione occasionale un
brutto momento
la domanda che mi viene posta più spesso
è ma quando finisce col
probabilmente non finirà questo virus
non non riusciamo a immaginare un modo
poi miracoli possono sempre accadere in
cui questo virus possa sparire possiamo
tornare alla vita di prima
questo ci terrorizza perché stiamo
vivendo in una situazione molto
difficile ma questo virus ripeto
difficilmente se ne andrà ed è molto
probabile che ne arriveranno altri già
vediamo queste varianti che emergono
abbiamo visto la variante omicron il
fatto di non avere vaccinato tutto il
mondo favorisce l'insorgenza di queste
varianti ma indipendentemente da questo
come è emersa la sars emersa la spurs
emerso sars core 2
gli scienziati ritengono che ci siano le
condizioni nel mondo perché
vengano nuovi virus e questa diventi
nera pandemica in cui noi ci
confronteremo con queste situazioni
continuamente questo è terribile se lo
diciamo così alla luce dell'esperienza
che stiamo vivendo ma appunto la ricerca
la scienza ci sta fornendo tutti gli
strumenti per poter entrare in questa
nuova era non come gli abitanti di siena
all'arrivo della peste ma con degli
strumenti validi per difenderci
importante che questi strumenti non li
condividiamo col resto del mondo e che
in tutto questo teniamo conto anche
appunto di queste nuove varianti di
questi nuovi virus che potrebbero
sorgere per questo gran parte della
ricerca sui nuovi vaccini in questo
momento non insegue tanto la variante
delta la variante o micro ma è molto
concentrata sullo sforzo di produrre un
nuovo vaccino pan coronavirus che riesca
a
difenderci almeno da tutti i virus della
famiglia della sars ma forse anche da
quelli della merse e chissà che un
giorno con questo vaccino potremmo anche
evitare il comune raffreddore che non è
una malattia grave ma che è così
fastidiosa per noi tutti i giorni e per
far questo bisogna sostenere la ricerca
bisogna avere fiducia nella scienza che
sta lavorando in questo ma ricordarsi
anche che c'è un altro ostacolo da
superare anche quando i vaccini ci sono
sono disponibili vediamo anche noi che
c'è un problema anche di accettazione da
parte delle persone
e allora la comunicazione che è una
scienza che ha le sue regole che ai suoi
strumenti dovrebbe essere utilizzata
anche questa non è un
approccio tecnologico la comunicazione
non è una nuova tecnologia ma è senza
dubbio uno strumento essenziale per
raggiungere questo obiettivo che è
quello di entrare in quest'era pandemica
senza paura ma con gli strumenti per
continuare la nostra vita godere di
quello tutto il bello che la vita ci può
dare
anche in un'era pandemica come quella
che si sta aprendo
[Musica]